(hip-hop beat)
- A big portion of 406
where I'm not in it
and it's like a day
of directing Ilana.
Which was such a pleasure 'cause
not having directed,
you get the full experience
when you're not in it.
When you're directing
and you're in it,
you're like, constantly
putting this hat,
and you're like, these hats,
and you're like putting
them on top of each other.
For me,
it's about setting
everything up and planning.
And so I can be in
the scene as an actor
as much as possible,
but then you're...
You are watching
your other actors in the scene
as the director.
It was fun but it
was like a lot.
- You're gonna be a hit here.
- Thanks.
- That Margot's a mighty witch.
- It's so exciting
working with these women.
I'm Jane Curtin and
I'm playing Margot.
- Like, insane.
She's an absolute joy.
So funny.
- I studied her as a
kid and a comedy nerd.
- [Abbi] She kept throwing
in surprising improv.
- She's amazing.
- [Abbi] My mom is an artist
and Jane's character Margot,
her table's all my
mom's actual artwork,
so my mom really liked that.
- There's a feeling on the set
that you feel free,
you feel safe.
So it's a pleasure being here.
- Margot!
Can you watch my
stuff for a second?
I got money to spend.
- Money is a
mind-control technique
that quantifies the
progress of the patriarchy!
Yeah, I'll watch your stuff.